vous évoquez des johnny hallyday a peut
être tardif
on rappelle que sa carrière débute en 59
donné l'idée c'est un enfant du
gaullisme c'est la france un peu alex la
france qui se puisse le blues c'est la
france 2 qu'au passé la porte de jacques
anquetil faire france jazzy c'est la
france des chaussettes noires et des
chats sauvages ont travaillé avec les
choses donc c'est un enfantement c'est
un enfant naturel du gaullisme c'est à
dire ici un des plus importants dégâts
des t bonds depuis le général de gaulle
oui c'est un gaulliste social droite
gauche c'est un gaulliste il d'agolli
delà de la brandit de la route époque je
dirais